bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette édition
d' espace autochtone en direct
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
à l'arctique à l'heure des changements
climatiques
ils sont de plus en plus nombreux ils
sont de plus en plus évident et pour en
parler en fait on nous allons parler
évidemment de la réalité actuelle des
enjeux mais également de la
collaboration avec les inuit là-bas sur
place en arctique pour en parler d'eux
invités je vous les présente tout de
suite alors la première josé gérin
lajoie bonjour bonjour madame gérin
lajoie vous êtes à l'université du
québec du québec à trois rivières
vous êtes titulaire de la chaire de
recherche du canada en écologie polaire
et boréal non ah non ça c'est votre
c'est votre collègue ça c'est nicolas
vous vous êtes au département des
sciences de l'environnement de
l'université du québec à trois-rivières
et au centre d'études nordiques
le centre d'études il est associé de
l'université du québec à trois rivières
en fait les chercheurs sont membres de
plusieurs inscriptions universitaires au
québec
d'accord d'ailleurs d'accord et nicolas
lecomte bonjour alors c'est vous qui
êtes à l'université de moncton kg est
titulaire de la chaire de recherche du
canada en écologie polaire et boréal ça
consiste en quoi rapidement la chaire de
recherche du canada
c'est une institution qui est financé
par le gouvernement du canada pour
essayer de pousser les recherches dans
différents domaines de la science
là chaque que j'ai la chance de diriger
particulièrement focus est sûr
comprendre les changements qu'il ya dans
le dans le nord est de savoir aussi
faire des ponts plus important avec les
communautés
notamment les communautés inuit d'accord
et puis sur le plateau également notre
chroniqueuse mathis harvey mathis
bonjour un jour avec vous aujourd'hui on
va parler aussi des conséquences des
changements climatiques et on va
s'intéresser aux ours polaires
exactement voilà et puis vous avez vous
allez le constater il n'ya pas dix huit
sur le plateau et ce n'est pas parce
qu'on n'a pas essayé bien au contraire
on ya mis toute notre énergie j'aurais
aimé aujourd'hui avoir un ou une inuit
qui vit les changements de prêt qui
connaît très bien cette réalité mais il
ya des incontournables la distance et
puis surtout la langue parce que la
plupart des inuit à travers le pays bon
évidemment parlent leur langue
maternelle
linou petit ou tout autre et parle pour
la plupart par le l'anglais et ça je
pense que vous le connaissez tous les
deux en tant que chercheur parce que
évidemment vous travaillez avec les
inuits sur le terrain est habituellement
ça se passe quoi en anglais
principalement là vos conversations josé
ou qu'ils répondent oui oui oui
principalement l'anglais en fait les
jeunes aux dunes à vic parle quand même
le français mais la première langue avec
laquelle on s'adresse à lui c'est
vraiment l'anglais et ça mais entre eux
ils vont parler bien sûr oui nicolas oui
moi c'est ce que moi j'ai vécu pendant
près de sept ans dans l'arctique
j'avais la chance de pouvoir entendre
l'inaptitude mais je dois avouer que je
suis pas excellent dans cette langue et
j'essaie de le faire le plus d'efforts
et de continuer à chaque fois que
maintenant je retourne dans le nord pour
le travail de passer du temps pour
continuer à apprendre la langue
oui oui et inversement c'est ça
évidemment les inuit oui apprennent une
langue seconde principalement l'anglais
le français aussi
alors je lance un appel à tous les inuit
à l'ecoute s'il y en a qui peuvent nous
suivre en français si oui qui ont envie
de participer à ce genre d'échangé
évidemment aller sur notre page facebook
allez allez vous vous faire connaître
pour qu'on puisse éventuellement vous
contacter et vous inviter sur ce plateau
alors on va commencer avec vous josé
parce que vous allez nous quitter à
12h45
donc la réalité sur le terrain vous la
connaissez très bien vous avez fait
beaucoup de recherches sur le terrain en
2007 j'avais eu l'occasion de vous
parler parce qu'à l'époque vous aviez
sorti un essai un essai où vous vous
intéressiez au caribou en fait le tel le
titre de votre recherche de votre essai
le caribou moi je les traduis en
français le caribou gouttes différemment
aujourd'hui
parce que justement vous êtes allés sur
place vous êtes allé rencontrer des
aînés des jeunes pour parler de leur
réalité et de ce qui se passe sur le
territoire
oui en fait parce qu'on entend souvent
la voie des scientifiques qui ont les
recherches dans nord mais nous on veut
intéresser leurs cahiers l'année polaire
internationale
on a eu des fonds pour en fait
interviews et des aînés pour qu'on peut
voir comment les gens qui vivent dans
nord qui commençait eux c'est quoi
qu'ils observent sur le territoire donc
on a fait une recherche à travers le
nunavik on a voté nunatsiavut mais deux
communautés 144 personnes interrogées
puis on a fait un peu une synthèse de
so2 sera en fait l'impact heureuse qui
perçoivent en fait au niveau des animaux
des insectes de bons plants du climat
même d'aider sur le mode de vie et ils
perçoivent beaucoup de choses il
constate beaucoup de choses
est ce que est ce que c'est partout en
arctique
je ne sais pas vous allez pouvoir me le
dire mais certains aînés et certains
habitants du grand nord constate des
changements de plus en plus important
oui oui c'est sûr ça change très
rapidement ils sont les premiers touchés
par ce parce que même au niveau des
déplacements la sécurité des
déplacements ou les périodes de chasse
avait vraiment un gros impact sur hull
le fait que la glace de mer
en fait tu prends plus tard l'automne
dégel plutôt louer au printemps donc ça
l'est vraiment un gros impact sur leurs
déplacements en fait la végétation qui
pousse plus qui est aussi un impact sur
les chemins ou le lizac l'accès certains
territoires puis en fait l'ailé les la
distribution des animaux si je dirais
qu'ils observent des changements des
nouvelles espèces d'insectes de poissons
d'oiseaux de passer ça bouge même de
mammifères qui sait ça bouge très vite
pe
en fait c'est un peuple s'est toujours
adapté mais là il voit un rythme qui
n'est pas qu'ils n'ont pas vu
précédemment
parce que eux-mêmes ont vécu plein de
changements au niveau social dans les
très rapidement donc c'est des gens qui
sait qu'ils sont très résilient et
s'adaptent le mieux au niveau de
l'environnement je pense que ça bouge ça
bouge oui oui oui
comment se déroule votre collaboration
avec eux quand vous allez sur le terrain
parce que vous travaillez
oui avec des aînés mais je le vois dans
d'autres études que vous avez réalisé
vous avez approché les jeunes aussi
comment ça se déroule en fait nous c'est
ça c'est tellement important l'aspect
éducation en fait après avoir fait tout
ce travail là avec les aînés on avait le
goût de les travers et les jeunes qui
sont les la prochaine génération en fait
ou qui vont être les premiers témoins en
fait de ces changements la clé les
premiers acteurs aussi les décideurs
dans le futur donc on ne voit ça a été
vraiment d'aller au travers l'éducation
scientifique de premièrement on était à
l'intérieur du corps et culot dans le
système scolaire on a décidé aussi
d'avoir des interventions que
directement avec la communauté
ce hors du cadre scolaire donc de
d'appliquer d'une communauté à dans un
suivi environnemental donc on appelle
commune tibet monitoring suivi
environnemental communautaire et pour
nous c'est vraiment important qui qui
accueille qui en fait ils ont toujours
été des maîtres de d'observateurs de l'
environnement mais de leur apporter
notre contribution en fait scientifique
allaient alors qu'étant si des hommes
oui vous nicholas sur le terrain ce que
vous voulez c'est ce sont en fait c'est
de détecter les changements qui se
produisent dans les écosystèmes polaire
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
on veut mesurer à la fois l'ampleur le
type de changements puis voir aussi les
pas seulement les changements moyens
mais l'alternance des changements il ya
beaucoup de défauts qui me pour
comprendre juste à l'accroissement de la
température mais c'est un des paramètres
parmi tous ceux qui sont à mesurer pour
mieux comprendre l'impact des
changements climatiques
on voit par exemple des changements dans
le pergélisol donc au nord du canada
dans la plupart de la région arctique le
sol et est composé de pairs jeudi salle
est donc un sol qui est gelé en
permanence
oui mais on voit qu'il peut y avoir des
grosses perturbations qui se produisent
quand il ya un réchauffement soit
accéléré soit brutale d'une année sur
l'autre et on peut avoir justement des
parties de milieux humides qui vont être
complètement drainé parce que la partie
qui protégeait ce milieu humide l'un est
devenu jeu s'est affaissé est devenu en
fait un vecteur pour que toute l'eau
s'en aille vers la perse vers ce nouveau
drame dont convoi d'aidé l'impact sur
les espèces notamment migratrices qui
dépend des milieux humides comme les les
oiseaux de rivage ils les canards les
oies on peut voir l'impact que ça sur la
disponibilité des habitants mais aussi
lors la possibilité de se survivre à ces
événements oui et quand vous êtes sur le
territoire de quelle manière est ce que
vous travaillez avec les gens des places
dans lesquels vous vous rendez et on a
un des sites ou qu'on retourne
régulièrement depuis 2013 on vit en
vivaient là comme un résidant du nunavut
en fait et on connaissait beaucoup les
personnes de façon un très proche donc
on en fait c'était comme visiter amis et
à aller avec eux dans la toundra pour
participer aux activités quand qu'on a
été bien de concerts a vécu et donc
avant qu'on fasse le travail dans le
nord à chaque année on fait une vague de
permis bien sûr à la fois scientifique
mais aussi on fait des consultations
avec rire les gens des communautés pour
voir quelles sont les leurs perceptions
des travaux mais aussi s'ils ont des
choses qu'on voudrait qu'on fait nous on
préfère ou des choses qu'il faudrait
changer et qui pourrait permettre de
répondre à leurs besoins aussi donc il
pas raison bien des des personnes qui
vont dire manger on aimerait que vous
compreniez qu'est ce qui se passe avec
cette espèce là il peut y avoir des
préoccupations sur le canigou peut avoir
des préparations sauver les ours
polaires et on peut leur dire à quelle
mesure nous on est capable de pouvoir y
répondre et ensuite sur le terrain mais
est ce qu'on est celle face et 2
notamment en début de saison au
printemps donc jusqu'à souvent fin juin
on est encore capable de déplacer sur la
banquise ans parce qu'il jouit on peut
justement aller avec les gens de la
communauté sur les différents sites de
mesure
posez les allées les technologies de
mesure avec eux et voir en fait
l'intérêt que les genres on a continué à
une telle mesure
voile intérêts sont capables de le faire
pour qu'ensuite ça devienne comme me
disait josé tantôt un suivi qui soit
fait avec la communauté ou et par la
communauté hindoue
donc ça c'est un principe de base qui
ont subi aussi on essaie de voir comment
on peut attirer l'intérêt des jeunes
générations
donc on fait les ateliers d'observation
d'oiseaux on part dans la toundra avec
les jeunes de la communauté on va leur
montrer quelles espèces sont présentes
dans tel milieu où d'autres et on amène
aussi des quelques savoir-faire que
qu'on essaie de partager avec les
étudiants qui vivent plus dans le sud du
canada mais qu'on pourrait justement
amenée transférer directement dans le
système d'éducation là pour pour le non
et j'allais parler aussi du des savoirs
traditionnels est ce que vous vous
servez des savoirs traditionnels des
communautés
lorsque vous allez étudier le territoire
l'un ou l'autre
en fait c'est la base de que de beaucoup
de travaux de recherche qui sont en fait
dans le nord pas seulement ce qu'on fait
dans nos dents dans la chaire de
recherche du canada
ici on a vraiment un besoin incroyable
de partage et puis en ce qui est le plus
grand défi c'est de pouvoir être capable
de bien comprendre cette savoir la
considérable et de pouvoir l'utiliser
de concert avec la communauté donc ça
c'est toujours un défi on n'est jamais
forcément préparé pour ça dans quand on
a une formation par exemple de
biologistes moi c'est ma formation je
n'ai pas forcément formés pour être
avoir une interaction avec les gens des
communautés mais en ayant vécu l'ordre
pendant beaucoup d'années en ayant ma
famille qui a grandi là ça nous a permis
vraiment d'avoir des liens forts et de
pouvoir justement construire à partir de
ces liens fort leur une meilleure façon
de d'utiliser le savoir
traditionnellement que ce soit dans les
deux sens que ce soit avec eux et enfin
avec oui avez-vous des exemples
justement d'éléments de savoirs
traditionnels qui vous ont servi dans
vos recherches notamment on voulait
savoir pour certaines espèces après de
la présence de certaines stations ont
beaucoup attiré pour les changements de
biodiversité et des fois on va noter des
affres des nouvelles espèces qui sont à
qui apparaissent dans certains décident
quand on travaille depuis quelques
années mais si on inclut pas le savoir
que les gens ont depuis plusieurs
centaines d'années dans ces sites là on
peut passer à côté d'eux justement de
nouvelles espèces qu'on pense que de
nouvelles espèces ne le sont pas ou
justement voir que c'est vraiment de
nouvelles espèces et on peut avoir cette
confirmation d'un sur une longue période
de temps avec deux concerts avec le
câble était alors que vous josé ça fait
partie intégrante de votre travail
d'aller collecter en fait le savoir
local vous vous vous le faites de façon
régulière
ben oui car en effet la campagne un peu
le qui a mené aux livres on faisait plus
exclusivement ça mais maintenant c'est
plus comme intègre et à travers comme
d'autres aspects de recherche
en fait nous en trop on étudie le en
fait là là on suit la santé d'une
rivière avec la communauté puis on
courait pour se déplacer sur la rivière
sans avoir l'idée des guides locaux qui
connaissent une rivière avec beaucoup de
rap et donc on s'en sert à chaque fois
le dire on pourrait aux dépens de en
fait pour tout notre logistique de de
terrain quand on voit avec les jeunes
mais laissé comme un cap sciences mais
en même temps c'est une collecte de
données réelles auxquelles jeunes
participants certains ces championnats
plus délicat qu'on doit faire nous mêmes
mais en fait c'est on amène toujours des
années avec nous puis comme j'ai
vraiment un échange de savoirs puis de
d'occasions c'est entre les électeurs et
leurs jeunes que l'on met en place comme
des conditions pour que le savoir se
transmettre entre eux mêmes certains des
jeunes maintenant certaines familles
sortant des communautés donc ça a créé
des espaces de
transmis son savoir dans les deux sens
comme zen coller mais entre les aînés et
leurs jeunes et entre les aînés et noue
entre les chercheurs les jeunes
c'était très riche leur avec les guides
mais cessons on dépend vraiment beaucoup
d'eux pour toute la connaissance du
territoire
parlez moi de la réalité en 2019 nicolas
vous l'avez dit vous avez habité sur le
territoire quelques années quels sont
les changements les plus importants et
les plus inquiétants que vous avez vu la
au cours des derniers mois des dernières
années nicolas l'isi moi ça fait 20 ans
que je travaille dans l'arctique
canadien
pire les plus gros est fait c'est sûr
que la température est et on peut le
mesurer mais c'est difficile à le
ressentir de façon directe mais on voit
les charges ont justement dans le
pergélisol qu'ils sont majeurs et avait
beaucoup de choses que ok haut niveau
qui oppose -des maintenant on y navigue
et poser des problèmes extrêmement
important en infrastructures à la fois
pour les routes les aéroports le
maintien des deux maisons dans les
communautés c'est quelque chose de très
criants et on voit aussi dans l'aide
dans le terrain en faisant le suivi des
espèces un animal où on voit des des
effondrements de sur le bord des
rivières ce sont souvent les zones où il
ya il ya des nids de rapaces qui vont
être présents - on va noter justement là
le déclin du nombre de ces décennies où
on peut voir aussi les le potentiel
drainage des zones humides qui sont des
milieux clé pour beaucoup des espèces
migratrices donc ça c'est des choses
qu'on voit et on voit aussi la plus
grande alternance de de changement peut
avoir on peut passer d'un d'une année
très froide elle est extrêmement chaude
relativement aux autres années et ça
peut être du jour au lendemain
perdre la banquise sur laquelle on se
baser pour travailler mais aussi pour
les communautés c'est la banquise qui
servait justement à l'y rejoindre des
zones de pêche et de chasse donc sa cdc
des changements très très marqué pas
forcément sur une longue période de
temps mais c'est sûr d'une année sur
l'autre des grandes des grands extrême
d'alternance oui alors la banquise qui
sert par exemple aux ours polaire à
pouvoir se déplacer
justement matisse il ya un impact donc
qui est très importante pour les ours
polaires de l'article oui exactement
mais en fait c'est ça on en parlait vous
le savez sans doute ce seul article
c'est la région où le réchauffement
climatique est deux à trois fois
supérieurs qui ailleurs sur le globe si
on apprenait aussi récemment dans un
rapport d'environnement canada qui a été
publié le 1er avril dernier que le nord
canadien
le réchauffement est avait lieu à un
rythme deux fois plus élevé qu'ailleurs
sur le globe depuis la fin des années 40
900 qui ravirent mais vous pouvez
confirmer c'est ces données-là josé vous
êtes d'accord aussi oui moi j'ai vu des
recul des glaciers communauté des
frappes en disant c'est justement la
hausse des températures elles entraînent
comme vous le disiez effectivement un
déclin de l'étendue des glaces des
meilleurs pendant l'été et ça à toutes
sortes d'effets notamment sur l'effet de
la réduction de l'effet albédo qui la
capacité d'une surface terrestre a
répliqué la lumière et la chaleur plutôt
que de l'absorber dans les seuls oui et
aussi sur les ours polaires parce que
ça complexifie pour eux la chasse aux
phoques sont leurs principales proies et
qui se reproduit sur les glaces de mer
et la question de l'ours polaire
justement est intéressante et assez
particulière parce qu'elle divise quand
même relativement beaucoup la communauté
scientifique et les inuit la communauté
scientifique va davantage converger vers
une conclusion qui est la suivante en
fait comme quoi le réchauffement
climatique et menaces l'habitat des ours
polaires donc de manière générale un
déclin est à prévoir à long terme
mais du côté des îles où et quand on
regarde le nunavut les inuits ont plutôt
tendance à avoir un discours plutôt
différent peut-être en avez vous entendu
parler dans les derniers dans les
derniers mois mais dans plusieurs
communautés en notes on les et nous et
ont de plus en plus noté qu'il y avait
des hausses polaire qui se rapprochent
des villages et qui menaçaient la
sécurité publique
et justement il ya eu deux blessés dans
l'est l'été dernier à are via teyana au
chat
les premiers depuis causés par des
attaques d'ours polaires depuis
plusieurs années sur le toit raison s'il
se déplacer se rapproche donc du côté
des nounous et on parle plutôt d'une
hausse de la population d'ours polaires
mais du côté de la communauté
scientifique on parle déclin causée par
lé réchauffement climatique et si je
pense que beaucoup de scientifiques qui
savent que jouer toulouse entend devenir
visible c'est ce que vous en dites oui
josé où nicolas êtes vous d'accord avec
les conclusions des scientifiques à ce
sujet là je devrais juniors c'est un peu
les propos qui fait que peut-être enfin
tienne partie des choses qui sont qui
peuvent se rejoindre dans les messages
ce qu'il y avait différentes populations
de douala
oui et chacune ont pas le même destin en
fait pour l'instant donc on a des
populations qui sont très bien suivi
qu'on connaît on a le maximum
d'informations et qui sont dans dans le
plus dans le sud de la baie du scion et
là c'est là qu'on voit les plus gros
changements dans la qualité de la glace
de mer du rire laquelle j'ai ce domaine
disponibles pour procès ces populations
cette population là et c'est là qu'on
voit un déclin dans la condition
physique est justement là où il ya les
plus grandes chances d'avoir des
conflits entre humains et ours polaires
parce que quand on peut pas aller
chercher sa nourriture sur la banquise
mais ils vont être plus souvent proches
des de la terre ils vont aussi aller
vers la nourriture facile notamment les
jeunes qui viennent des d'émanciper de
leur mère puis les maires qui ont besoin
plus d'énergie vont être soit en vue
projeter des dons publics exactement ça
sent donc c'est surtout à ceux ci est
donc au changement climatique donc le
constat reste un peu le là l'origine du
problème
je pense que la nuance est plutôt là il
ya un autre point qui divise un peu
c'est celle du dénombrement en fait sur
le nombre de sous population d'ours
polaires qu'on retrouve dans l'eau
souvent il ya des techniques de
dénombrement aérien donc par survol par
avion qui sont effectués pour dénombrer
les populaces il est sous population
d'ours polaires mais ce que certains
chasseurs contredisent un peu là dedans
c'est que les ours polaires vont disent
que les ours polaires vont plus plus
souvent à les chasser dans des
conditions extrêmes de tempêtes de
brouillard ou la visibilité pour les
pour les avions est plus restreint donc
plus difficile de noter donc de
dénombrer le nombre d'ours polaires mais
celle où est-ce qu'ils sortent le plus
parce que peuvent plus facilement se
dissimuler pour aller chasser les
phoques
donc est-ce que la tulle et
l'interprétation des résultats du nombre
peut peut être sujette à certaines
différences peut-être est un point qui
est qui qui est soulevée par certains
chasseurs mais c'est sûr que oui il ya
toujours des incertitudes liées aux
inventaires aériens
et puis encore à noter qu'il ya
différentes populations et la qualité
des données est pas la même partout donc
il ya des zones les plus étudiés c'est
là on a les meilleurs précision comme là
où il ya justement la zone potentielle
avec le plus grand déclin mais dans la
plupart de la surface d'occupation dans
l'eure dans la distribution de l'ours
polaire on a relativement peu de données
les inventer avance hommage au mieux aux
cinq ans et sinon plus et donc c'est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir des bonnes
prédictions association donc les les
défis sont encore plus grands pour pour
ces zones là c'est là encore le plus
important de bien
les savoirs traditionnels le savoir
local et bien sûr les travaux qui
peuvent être faits et de façon concertée
pour que je te demande puisse comprendre
c'est vrai que les eaux sont sont les
appelle un peu comme des fantômes le ici
vont être présent quand il fait tempête
quand on est pris dans une tempête dans
en train de camper il sait c'est là où
les risques sont les plus grands de les
rencontrer parce que il s'en sert pour
chasser ça c'est certain
par contre il y à des travaux qui sont
faits pour faire du capteur capture
marquage rocade sud donc ça c'est un
moyen qui ont marqué un animal un peu
ensuite leur voix ou pas le revoir et
avec ça on peut estimer avec les
probabilités qu'il survive et probité
qui soit à détecter ou pas et donc on
peut séparer les erreurs de son dû à
l'inventaire de la vraie survie ou de la
taille de population donc ça c'est le
sait les efforts qui sont les plus
peut-être pertinent pour mu arrimer les
a
les observations sur le terrain par les
par les différentes personnes oui pour
ceux qui nous écoutent et peut-être tout
à l'heure vous soulignez le nombre le
long bail après plusieurs types de sous
population d'ours polaires ceux qui nous
écoutent et qui se pose la question on
en retrouve 13 corrigez moi si je me
trompe
du côté du gouvernement fédéral on parle
de la population canadienne d'ours
polaires et 2 représente les deux tiers
de la population d'ours polaires au
monde
ils sont répartis sur cinq pays à savoir
les états unis donc on n'a pas ce canada
y en a pas juste au niveau ici au canada
et en alaska en norvège en russie et au
groenland et ces cinq pays la consigne
en 73 une un accord sur la conservation
de l'ours polaire est que cet accord lui
est notamment interdit la chasse
sportive non réglementé mais dans les
données mais dans les données les plus
récentes en parmi toutes les sauces
population d'ours polaire dans le nord
canadien en 2014 le gouvernement fédéral
ont dénombré à peu près 14 mais il peut
être avez vous des chiffres plus récents
ça fait je ne serai pas sur les chiffres
étant donné l'incertitude et à la
population puis mon avis le 14 mai il
est et surtout sur les populations où on
a les meilleures données mais celles qui
ont souffert de manque d'inventaire ou
justement aucun inventaire du tout
depuis plus de quinze et années et plus
je pourrai pas je pourrai pas confirmer
ça mais c'est sûr que l'essentiel de la
population d'ours
voilà est tout nouveau et ça donne une
fête à une responsabilité encore plus
grande pour le canada en termes de
gestion et de coordination avec les
communautés parce que c'est c'est leur
habitat et c'est celle-là que si on veut
avoir en fait une meilleure appréhension
de qu'est ce qui va se passer
c'est là qu'il faut travailler alors
avant de poursuivre sur les ours
polaires parce que josé doit nous
quitter à la cour qui commence dans quoi
15 minutes à peu près josé on va laisser
les ours polaires parce que ce n'est pas
votre champ d'étude mais dans votre
champ d'étude qu'est-ce que vous avez
constaté actuellement qui est le plus
préoccupant pour vous au niveau de
l'environnement
absolument oui en fait ce qu'on observe
beaucoup c'est celle assez choisirait de
l'atome drôle non je peux lui mais comme
le mentionnait nicolas c'est donc les
charges au niveau du drainage des sols
ok les pergélisols qui dégèle oui je
pense que c'est une des choses les plus
uniques des glissements de terrain
c'est les choses qui sont en fait le
réchauffement de l'eau si je dirais
aussi que comme un impact sur les
espèces consommées par les inuit donc
l'onglet article l'article cher je pense
que c'est quelque chose que le goût de
certains poissons ou de l'avenir sur
traditionnel qui est altérée en fait des
populations qui deviennent captif dans
des lacs intérieurs où je pense que
c'était la distribution des animaux
l'assèchement du territoire et les
précipitations qui sont en fait comme
telle elle mentionnait très il ya
vraiment des beaucoup de plus d' extrême
dans les événements qui me l'année
dernière et fallu avant de partir de la
rivière attendent le 29 juin pour
clairière dégel ces tuiles de cette
année et déjà des gelées depuis une ou
deux semaines
donc c'est vraiment un mois et demi
d'écart entre le dis j'ai de l'envié de
la rivière d'une d'une année à l'autre
qui énorme puis les prestations de neige
c'était cet hiver j'étais là au bout
tant pis s'il n'y avait du jamais vu il
y avait jamais vu autant de neige donc
des gels de plus en plus soit très très
tard ou soit très très tôt beaucoup de
neige ou les été très sec ou de la
fraude et des incidents de fait une
drogue et qui inquiets mais pas avant
parce que c'était plus une plume et donc
ça c'est sûr que c'est ce qui ne peut
viser pour moi et quelles sont les
grandes inquiétudes des habitants sur
place dont des inuit qui vivent là en
fait je pensais tout ce qui touche leur
l'alimentation traditionnelle c'est ça
qui vaut beaucoup les préoccupent et
entre autres ben postes au niveau de
l'environnement les changements
climatiques mais aussi toutes les
activités humaines entre autres les
mêmes des choses comme ça ça y est en
fait nous c'est ça qui est comme
déclenché qui été le déclencheur du
projet donc mes activités humaines sur
le territoire qui peuvent avoir un
impact sur la ligne sur la santé de
l'environnement qui ultima vont avoir un
impact sur la nourriture dont les
aliments doris nourrice qui sont encore
très importants dans leur mode de vie
que ça soit petits fruits viande traitée
comme le caribou les poissons d'autres
espèces les oiseaux mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui est pris en cubes
beaucoup en fait c'est vraiment le c'est
comme ça fait vraiment partie intégrante
de leur mode de vie puis si ça c'est
affecté existe mais qu'est ce qu'on va
devenir
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils ne sont pas
autour de la table avec nous aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'ils aimeraient entendre de
votre bouche qu'est ce qu'ils aimeraient
partager avec nous ils ne peuvent pas le
dire mais peut-être que vous
le dire à leur place puisque vous les
côtoyer beaucoup ouais mais je pense que
le principal message mais quels jeux
d'antan c'est que de plus en plus les
inuit veulent faire partie de la
solution qu'ils veulent a été intégrée
dans les processus de recherche et dans
les processus de décision
puis bon c'est ce que moi je retiens
qu'il ne principal message de leur point
de vue oui parce que ça ne se fait pas
encore ou très peu mais ça se fait de
plus en plus ça se fait de plus en plus
mais vraiment encore place pour
améliorations pour que soit ma des
acteurs du changement pour les décisions
qui vont être prises parce que c'est eux
qui les vivent là en fait tout le temps
qu'ils subissent ces changements le
département le plus drastique donc
qu'ils soient consultés qu'ils fassent
partie vraiment des décisions et des
trois niveaux politiques
oui avant de vous laisser si on veut
lire vos recherches entre autres
justement sur ce fameux caribou qui ne
goûte plus comme autrefois
ou est-ce qu'on peut diriger pour lire
vos études se développent et et avait
été publié en collaboration avec le hcc
disponible sur amazon
ennahdha mais on écrit on fait des
articles de vulgarisation aussi le bon
la revue bovine beyond de fuster qui sur
tous les avions dans nord ont fait des
rapports aussi pour la communauté en
étant très développé un site web
actuellement sur les projets qu'on fait
piéger ce pensionnaire peut-être avant
de partir on a gagné un prix identique
inspiration pour cette année qui ont son
retrait en travers la diffusion et à
développer de nouveaux outils de
diffusion aussi qu'ils sont interactifs
dont entre autres des cartes qui était
de savoir local et les connaissances
scientifiques à la fois sur une même
carte
donc soyez books chose à un dégoût et
moi oui merci beaucoup
madame gérin lajoie je rappelle que vous
êtes professeur vous êtes chercheur au
département des sciences de
l'environnement et au centre d'études
nordiques de l'université
et du québec à trois rivières je vous
laisse aller rejoindre vos étudiants
merci beaucoup mais j'ai juste pourquoi
mesures internes âge pas professeur
marché professionnel de recherche
ah c'est vrai oui ok alors aujourd'hui
donc ce n'est pas une classe d'étudiants
que vous allez voir qu'est-ce que vous
faites aujourd'hui
en fait notre réunion de terrain de
préparation des équipes de terrain qui
va être au prochain camp science avec
donc le tout les jeunes des étudiants et
des professionnels
il marchait pas l'organisation donc
c'est ça que c'est notre première équipe
réunion d' équipes de terrain pour le
caractère vierge non ok alors je vous
laisse les reculs et merci merci
beaucoup merci au revoir au revoir au
revoir
alors nicolas on poursuit avec vous et
avec avec mathis matisson par les dons
de l'ours polaire est ce qu'on est rendu
à dire que le le lourd cédant en
extinction en voie d'extinction non on
peut parler d'un sanctions en fait
justement on parlait tout à l'heure de
gestion le rôle du canada dans la
gestion tous à des espèces
particulièrement en cas de l'ours
polaire est un sous comité qui fait
partie du comité sur la situation des
espèces en péril au canada ce ce
sous-comité là qu'ils formaient de
dyslexie d'une dizaine d'experts s'est
réuni récemment l'automne dernier pour
mettre à jour le statut de
des sources polaire est en fait ce
qu'ils ont recommandé au gouvernement
fédéral c'est que le jour ce polar garde
le même statut d'espèce préoccupant donc
ça c'est le titre exact qui leur avait
été qui leur avait été officiellement
attribués en 2011 par le gouvernement
fédéral est ce que c'est ce statut des
caisses préoccupante en fait c'est le
niveau d'urgence le plus bas qui est
employé pour désigner les espèces
sauvages qui sont particulièrement
sensibles aux activités humaines et aux
catastrophes naturelles mais qui sont
pas suffisamment danger pour qu'on
puisse parler d'espèces en péril la
disparition de deux menaces réelles en
fait donc c'est souvent utilisé par les
experts pour parler d'un camp contre
camp les scientifiques sont convaincus
qu'un problème bon et puis qu'il faut le
surveiller mais qu'on n'a pas
nécessairement mesure de déterminer le
seuil le niveau exact où la population
sera seront menacés ou est-ce qu'on
propre servait un déclin au final non
mais qu'est ce que vous en pensez
monsieur de compte est ce que le statut
d'espèce préoccupante est encore
correcte dans le cas de l'ours polaire
pour avoir été pour être membre de ce
comité là moi même un qui totalement
d'accord avec le avec le la décision qui
a été prise c'est une décision fait qui
a été prise avec beaucoup de travail
derrière
à foix de consultation de révision des
meilleures informations disponibles
donc c'est toujours basé sur cet art
ross les meilleures informations
disponibles au moment où on fait la
révision du statut et s'est aussi fait
de concert avec les communautés
donc il ya en fait une partie du causse
et oui qui est basée sur leurs
des consultations et aussi l'utilisation
du serveur traditionnel pour un mieux
comprendre en fait les s'il faut changer
le statut ou s'il faut le repenser des
fois aussi on peut ne pas avoir changé
mon statut mais on peut avoir des
changements de conditions dans laquelle
l'espèce est présent et les risques
aussi peuvent avoir changé depuis la
dernière révision et c'est ça chaque
révision en fait se fait dans un horizon
de 10 ans donc il peut y avoir beaucoup
de choses qui peuvent se passer dans
cette période là et des fois on peut
avoir justement des des gros changements
qui arrivent d'un seul coup mais c 'est
le produit de dix années de
d'accumulation oui est-ce que ce statut
les il concerne les ours polaires
partout dans le cercle polaire en fait
dans tous les pays du centre polaire
dans le nord canadien en fait c'est ce
qu'ont utilisés les espèces en péril
justement si ceci oui et puis je pense
que les prochaines recommandations la
prochaine fois vous allez vous pencher
sur la question de l'ours polaire c'est
en fait les recommandations sont émises
je pense aux prévu pour 2020 de suite on
a commencé en fait le processus avant
2018 pour être un trait pour 2018 puis
donc dans d'ici dix ans il y aura une
réévaluation kiwis qui est déjà établie
et je dois dire aussi c'est que beaucoup
des points qui sont émis dans le
derrière en fait cette évaluation là
c'est le encore le manque de données
malgré le fait que ce soit très étudiée
par rapport à beaucoup deux espèces en
péril au canada qui souvent manque de
beaucoup de données c'est la majorité
d'entre elles en fait malgré quand même
tous les efforts et la concertation avec
tous les paliers gouvernementaux avec
les communautés pour réévaluer sa il
nous manque encore des informations
précieuses pour toujours améliorer notre
notre précision
mon évaluation surtout sur donc l'impact
d'imaginer de la fonte des glaces sur
sur les ours polaires
oui parce qu'ils peuvent toujours y
avoir des effets aussi intermédiaires
qui sont difficiles à prévoir parce
qu'on n'a pas forcément des données en
arrière pour ça et on peut avoir des
effets qui sont qui peuvent même être
bénéfique à court terme on peut avoir en
fait dans certaines parties de la
distribution de l'espèce notamment
canada en fait de même si la glace est
de moins bonne qualité pour pour les
humains pour le transport ça devient de
la glace de haute qualité pour pour les
populations de proie
des sources comme les phoques a mené par
exemple qui aime beaucoup en fait
justement dès qu'il ya beaucoup de
relève dans la glace qui a beaucoup
d'abris
mais ça devient aussi donc un habitat de
kde plus haute qualité donc il peut y
avoir dans certaines régions des effets
du réchauffement qui peut être bénéfique
à court terme mais par contre on sait
pas à long terme qu'est ce que ça va
parce que de toute façon l'habitat
de glace vin va réduire c'est sûr mais
il nous manque encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur les l'état des glaces
côtières
donc on a beaucoup d'incompréhension sur
les glaces ouverte sur dont les gants
dans les grandes surfaces marine mais
sur toute proche des côtes dans les
forces est toujours là qu'on a le plus
grand manque de précision et c'est là
que les travaux sur le terrain et la
collaboration avec la communauté est
cruciale ces années-ci peau mais oui
mieux prévoit qu est ce qui va se passer
oui et puis justement peut-être en avez
vous entendu parler dans les derniers
mois en fait ça fait 2 en 2014 depuis
2014 le gouvernement du nunavut
veulent en veut publier plan de gestion
/ / concernant les ours polaires
ils ont notamment déposé au ils ont
proposé l'automne dernier lors des
consultations publiques avaient lieu
dans tout le territoire
seule une version provisoire une version
préliminaire de ce plan de gestion là et
ils ont consulté consulter les
populations c'est toujours à ce plan et
tout se fait toujours attendre qu'ils
devaient être développées on connaît le
contenu il ya des estimations qui ont
été faites justement sur sur les sous
pulls elle le dénombrement des sous
populations et toutes les influences que
que là c'est cheap sous-population là
peuvent avoir sur les quotas de chasse
justement donc on n'a pas pu me dire au
gouvernement du nunavut quand est ce que
le plan allait sortir mais on l'attend
toujours là pour les semences et depuis
2014 oui ça fait cinq ans que l'on est
en plein oui mais il faut bien aussi
encore en perspective c'est un des plans
extrêmement complexe à mettre en scène
et toi qui est le tiers du canada très
vaste puis moi j'ai été personnellement
aussi un biologiste gouvernement du
nunavut et je comprends bien les défis
qui adore de produire ça parce qu'on
doit consulter toutes les communautés
qui sont toutes séparées par des
mimiques km en général oui
il faut que le timing soit bon on peut
pas faire les consultations quand les
gens sont partis à la chasse qui est une
activité importante donc il faut qu'on
arrive toutes les agendas ensemble puis
aussi le manque de données donc il y
avait des fois des des plans qui sont en
cours mais qui vont prendre du temps
parce que on attendait des nouveaux
inventeur qui vont rentrer dans les
années subséquentes et qui vont
permettre d'être plus précis dans le
plan ça veut pas dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'action qui sont prises en amont et en
attend de tels rapports il ya toujours
une gestion qui est roi qui est fait
une collaboration très très grande entre
les justement les les communautés les
chasseurs qui est le gouvernement le
nouveau t1 rapportage des deus qui ont
été prélevés et ça c'est une banque
d'informations incroyable pour pour
mieux gérer géré en collaboration mais
aussi de pour faire des recherches
scientifiques sur sur les populations
alors la suite pour les ours polaires ce
sera quoi en conclusion matisse mais je
pense qu'il va falloir attendre de voir
je pense que c'est davantage de
recherches probablement sur
sur l'impact finalement de la fonte des
glaces sur les ours polaires il ya des
questions qu'il faut ce qu'on se pose et
qui reste un peu en suspens quelles
seraient par exemple la proportion d'eau
scolaire s'ils doivent compter
exclusivement sur une alimentation
terrestre par exemple donc je d'ici à la
prochaine rencontre aussi du sous-comité
de ce plan de gestion je pense que et de
ces nouveaux chiffres je pense que
faudra voir où est ce qu'on en est que
vous consultez toujours les inuit vous
disiez nicolas l'heure pour eux l'ours
polaire est ce que c'est une inquiétude
parce que c'est quand même aussi la une
subsistance pour eux la chasse aux ours
polaires c'est quand même vraiment le
duo importante pour les communautés mais
aussi au niveau culturel au niveau même
c'est le symbole du nunavut et des
territoires du nord-ouest aussi raison
que c'est à ne pas oublier donc c'est
l'espace glissé l'espace importante
culturellement et aussi pour la sécurité
liée aux notamment l'utilisation de
dépôt et les gens aussi consomme en
somme les eaux fossiles
oui je pense que la question est aussi
le défi va être de mesurer non seulement
l'impact de cette évolution des sous
populations d'ours polaires sur les les
inuit mais aussi sur l'ensemble du
réseau trophique sur le toutes les
autres espèces animales qu'on retrouve
dans nord oui mais on parle d'un
prédateur clé donc c'est ce quand il
arrive plus souvent sur ta présent plus
souvent dans les zones injustement de
reproduction des oiseaux migrateurs on
voit les conséquences sur ces espèces là
on voit que ils sont capables d'aller
même dans des dans des falaises
verticale qu'avec notre équipement
moderne où on a des fournées italie on
va trouver des ours polaires en train
d'aller chercher des oeuvres de
déguisements on peut aller voir
justement des sources
nager d'univers à l'autre qui sont
pourtant des zones normalement protégés
pour certaines espèces vont devenir des
espèces qui vont être des dés la
nourriture complémentaires pour cette
espèce là donc ça c'est présent à
travers la distribution de l'ours
polaire il ya des beaucoup de travaux
comptait fermer ton dans l'archipel du
svalbard en norvège où on voit vraiment
l'impact sur des oies migratrices sur
les sternes et c'est la même chose aussi
au canada il ya plusieurs sites où les
gens voient en fait même sur une échelle
de temps assez courte le changement
drastique de prélèvements faits pour les
autres on doit on doit terminer parce
que leur leur achève pour continuer à
suivre vos travaux on va aller sur le
site l'université de moncton monsieur le
comte rappelle que vous êtes titulaire
de la chaire de recherche du canada en
écologie polaire et boréal à
l'université de moncton vos travaux on
peut les lire et les voir ou rapidement
donc ça sur le site américain on a accès
à toutes les pages des professeurs et
oui on a des liens justement vers nos
publications scientifiques
ce soit qu' on essaie de les rendre le
plus disponible possible
nous venons de perdre monsieur le comte
ça se terminer à 13 heures pile donc la
conclusion de sion elle est là mathis
merci beaucoup lui fait d'avoir partager
vos connaissances sur le sujet également
merci affidés et nous étions à écouter
l'émission veulent veulent
éventuellement venir en parler je pense
que la place est là elle est là autour
de la table avec nous merci à vous aussi
d'avoir été présent une nouvelle fois je
vous retrouve et nous vous retrouvons la
semaine prochaine pour un autre espace
autochtone en direct au revoir
oh
[Musique]